it's been simply had two people on him
as he's stepping up the house like I
don't understand like I believe if the
person is why is he let out I do not
understand why is he let out if you know
the guy is dangerous you know he's gonna
cause this and you've got two guys on
him in order for me to not prove them
wrong and stand up I have to go and be
like yes let's go and kill them you
pervert it because my teacher is online
is messenger your teacher is Bush and
George Bush and twenty play because
you're seeing they're doing it was will
do the same
[Music]
but I shall open
lady so hot limo feed the mob
what then
as we know there was an attack terror
attack that happened in Stremme
yesterday and what we want to do is like
we want to go into this person's mind
yeah because there's attacks happening
yeah and they all carrying this fake but
I think even before that we should give
our condolences of those affected yes
yes you know and for some reason he
picked an area which there is as well so
I wouldn't be surprised of some
countries Muslims is regardless mom
saying you know because these people
they're on such a level of fanaticism
that they I don't think they see Muslims
to them all of us we are all in the same
camp we we are my course online Islam
Plus yeah it's called extremism Islam's
about to be really soon shocked so
extremist lamps a textual approach I go
through the ideological underpinnings of
theological justifications that's why
many of these people would do what they
do
the course is divided into two parts the
first part are deals of things like for
example do all Muslims are also
commanded to fight and kill the
non-believers
yes that's a common thing this is
probably what he believed is all Lord
knows best
yeah many of them do especially Isis and
the like and I think other texts and
things that are used by these people to
promote and to justify they believed it
the discourse of the rest of the sort or
the first episode also the hadith had to
be still enough for them we said so mr.
nobody knows I've been ordered to
command to fight the people until they
believe that there's no except Allah so
on and so forth and I'm not these kind
of things the second part of the course
it really concerns Muslims themselves so
sintra Muslim kind of discussion and
really the whole discussion is synthetic
fear and the concept of tech fierro
excommunication and taking one rendering
someone outside the fold of Islam
because it's used by a lot of the
extremist groups as a tool of
justification to justify spilling the
blood of a Muslim we do that the
previous course the previous part of the
course and so surely I'll be coming soon
hopefully next week before that's an
online platform Salaam Plus which you
can come and sign up for and plus dog
day you can learn a few guys there's
anyone watching this and sadly has been
brainwashed by thinking
now carrying out these attacks on
innocent civilians is going to somehow
help Islam you're doing an absolute
disservice to us you're misrepresenting
our religion you are actually maybe a
part reason why our region's being
attacked so absolutely no if you can
watch this insha'Allah and maybe
hopefully come to your senses and not
take innocent lives so this video is the
suspect looks like a device it's a hoax
the police clear the streets
then more arrived there there within
minutes because a suspect they've just
killed had been under their watch and
this is the end of a police surveillance
operation several people had been
stabbed by the suspect some were treated
by passers-by
who saw the horror on the Sunday
afternoon or English drama helicopter
and land on the common right in front of
us and then there were
police and ambulances driving about we
had assumed that there had been a car
accident
that's what and then we walked up this
road just here and came to talk about
their and they were armed police
everywhere there were people everywhere
they're armed police look like they were
crouching down over someone shouting
it's all to get back just pushing it
further down the road ITV News
understands the suspect was 21 year-old
Sudesh a man who was released from
prison one week ago he was jailed in
2018 after admitting 13 terror offences
and expressing a desire to carry out his
own terror attack okay this is the
question that first you ask before we go
in to go into this guy's mind so like
how were they how would they let you
know this guy when he's clearly been
he's been has said that he want to carry
that things you don't know if he said
this whilst in prison wasn't a new
sentence okay I mean when I was in
prison I saw okay once you're in prison
people are gonna feel okay oh it's okay
I was in prison for those who don't know
my past go into what my podcast was
dealing Hossein Blood Brothers podcast
also we did want cinnamon so at school I
used to be read to cool so I was
convicted previously denied in 2000 is
about 12 years ago eight for terror
offense I was initially planned to go to
understand and I discussed in those
podcasts the reasons why my psychology
at the time so maybe if you don't want
to go to a podcast just disappears like
let's ask yourself like what what led
you to take up up because you're not
coming from this because this guy wants
anyone's blood absolutely you was more
of like invading forces absolutely
businesses or pressure on the Muslim I
felt that the Muslims were being
victimized or being attacked and no one
was there to defend them nor was there
to protect them protect the owner so on
and so forth and justification to allow
myself to travel to permit myself to
travel and do to try and so forth that
was it in a nutshell but what happened I
mean you didn't make it obviously you
got arrested
of course you're so yeah when I was in
Turkey
back Anderson vs. history right now with
me i saw i saw i saw depression that was
taking place and i felt that there was
no one there to support that was
protecting monsters break the rise of
the muslims and i found that i became
slowly alienated from society from the
mainstream Muslims I thought that no one
was talking I felt our scholars were not
talking about it and everyone was quiet
and and I found I'm obviously I kind of
mentioned there but I'm a person who
when I seen justice I can't deal with it
how it has to be turned in the right way
and so I saluted myself online I found a
safe space I found people that I could
communicate with them one and we know
that and there's a lot of research there
piece suggest although there's nothing
conclusive but online if it doesn't
promote extremism or promote the
radicalization of people it definitely
Foster's it so increase the safe
environment yes this is just coming up
but I experienced it myself for it so I
can I can I can testify to that and I
found that I saw it slowly started speak
to like my beautiful people treat these
books were exchanged and people
espousing these kind of views were
exchanged so on and so forth I still at
that time I wouldn't say that I became a
Muslim nowadays to qadi so I never
convinced that northern I fall into the
extremes of what this person was either
that make sense it was literally case
for me that I believed it was justified
to go out there and to join the forces
to fight against repelling I mean and
that was in I think it's blessing from
Allah and get that for because super
honest with you if I did get therefore
then you know Allah knows best right
this kind of dangerous ideology yeah
and so that's much I'm not sure I don't
take away from the viewers let them go
watch it before the league's third to
the put all right